what's the next steps for now red then
what's what's the goal or is it just
make more videos because you don't
upload a lot I quit yeah
the meth lab finally takes off yeah no
no because it's always it's always like
you know a push and pull between math
and right now the meth is like right
right the best popping off dude once the
market goes like you know a little bit
down like that he's got the cover done
so it's like depends on what the the CPM
yeah that's actually why I only post
videos every few months is because you
know meth production what is the reason
why your video just takes a lot like
what's the main like what's is it just
everything okay so I assume it's just
like a lot of testing right yeah it's
honestly putting the video together oh
really is like the last video to put to
the last video was the hardest it took
me I think I I like to say like two and
a half months of full-time work where I
say like there's no weekends like you're
just working yeah as much as you can
every day for two more months that's the
film and then to edit was like a month
and a half a bit over a month on you
edit all your videos yeah oh my God
because I promise you have so many
videos you have all this like random
data you've collected and I have to put
it all together but they have to do the
research to like present it and I have
to figure out the ways to present it so
are you interesting a thesis every time
you do a video I think she is doing this
some of them take just forever right um
but like why they take a really long
time to post it depends on the project
like some of you some things I've filmed
in like a day and I edited in like four
days this was like two years ago it
depends on what you're that was like the
peak when I could do a video in a week
um but I've realized I like the ones
that take a while yeah and now I'm
trying to figure out like how to balance
I like I really like the filming part
but the editing is you got to get
yourself an editor bro but it's not the
actual Act of editing right it's like
decide like the biggest problem for me
is like how do I present all the
information
so like for example I'll have let's say
I don't know unfair fluid or one of the
things I've done
I will literally have like let's say 30
different things that I'm like I have to
mention this or it doesn't make sense
and it's like where do I mention it
because the thing I hate in I don't hate
it in science videos but I don't like
taking pauses to explain things it's
like everything I explain has to be when
it's relevant right that makes sense you
don't like like massive information
dumps right no so it's like if I'm gonna
mention this point it's only at a point
that it's relevant right so I have to
then take time to write and put all
these points in at certain parts right
it's like what parts do I include what
don't I include and then I have to like
watch my own videos and then be like I
did this and then let's say color
changes why there's no documentation
yeah so I have to go and look at it and
it's like I could hire somebody there's
no notes they just have raw video right
sometimes it's like a terabyte and a
half of just raw video yeah and they
don't even know what happens in the clip
but I know that out of the four 40
minute clip that twice in it I added
something right and the color doesn't
even change but I remember so it's like
I know where to find those clips and
look for certain things yeah and I I
mean so you you upload these videos it
takes you so long right and does is
YouTube how does YouTube view it is it
like do they demonetize it often or is
it age restricted because I wonder like
what how they like what's the CPM on
like those kinds of content like is it
what I wanted to watch gaps in time or
what is it like what does it like
categorize it as yeah education
educational education
I think it's it's that the long videos
I've been doing are definitely worth it
yeah because like in between posting
videos the AdSense doesn't really change
right so it's like when I posted it
spikes and then it goes like after like
two weeks it goes down but then it just
doesn't change yeah right and you have
infinite rewatchability because I watch
it like full time because I have no
[ __ ] clue what happened that's the
figure yeah that is why I keep getting
better nine million times it's like it's
just that the scientists re-watching it
10 times to figure out how to make a
fair well actually I think when we look
at the videos the average video the
average person who's watched the video
has seen it twice wow I mean people
people do apparently come back at a
confusion I think sometimes I don't have
to because there's so much presented to
you uh to you like at once yeah and as
someone who has zero knowledge of
chemistry you have to cut out like yeah
it's very common do you do you get a lot
of people telling you that your voice is
just relaxing and then you just play
your videos and they don't even know
what's going on yeah I've done that a
few times because I'm just like I need
something in the background yeah so I
just play you because it's like it's
constant it's like you don't change
inflection that's part of like
it's not the that's what makes the
voiceover hard yeah because like I try
to make it the most unintrusive ever it
is it's very much there's no like you
you don't like uh you're the way you're
talking is no the speed doesn't change
the volume doesn't change you've like
you're very good at it that's
that's honestly like props to you
because that's not easy like a lot of
people do very rookie mistakes when
they're recording and they the first
thing the first word they'll say often
is the loudest
so I learned how to not do that and like
at one point I tried to get like uh
compressors and everything to try but I
don't I just don't use any of that
anymore but even though like when you're
recording you can tell when a compressor
is compensating like you can hear I
don't like artifacts so yeah I will I
don't like you yeah I don't use any of
like the plugins but I yeah I learned
and it's like I never really looked it
up I just I just would hear the audio
and hate certain things that's funny and
then try to find out like the one was
like the lip smacking
so it's like all the mouth noises I just
couldn't stand I use plugins to get rid
of them oh I do so here's the thing okay
I still do because you can't stop that
you can't no no no there's no training
on Earth I remember watching some videos
and they're like when you speak lift
your lip off your teeth yeah like get
used to just not touching your lips to
your teeth when you speak do I do that
so I caught I've never done [ __ ] no I'm
super self-conscious about this [ __ ] but
I'm not saying like fully but like I've
consciously like tried to not and I
noticed it made it so that I I went from
like if you if you don't listen to my
early video you hear a lot more mouth
noises well this it's mainly zoo with
how much water you're drinking and the
patient you're drinking it so you want
to like drink a lot of water you want to
sip congratulations you're recording if
you drink too much it it will sound
really [ __ ] Slappy yeah if you're too
little your lips will be like bone
[ __ ] broad you still need you
definitely still need to do the plug-in
to remove it oh yeah because it's
natural like everyone has it yeah but
it's one of those things that when
you're listening to someone naturally
you just don't hear it but all I don't
know it's like the mic seems to pick it
up even more yeah yeah and yeah and
there's another another thing you can do
if you are having the problem of your
YouTuber while you're talking and you
start because you know you do a redo but
you start the sentence halfway so how do
you make it sound like you've done the
sentence right so you say something
before it so you go like okay now this
is what I'm gonna do so then the first
now isn't as loud yes because normally
if you go the okay I'll do another one
right now and then you Trail in so like
exactly and like I find that what do I
do is you say the end of the couple
words from the last sentence that helps
a lot yeah but what I would find is
starting with T's and other stuff yeah
even when you Trail in they're pretty
it's hard bad let's get used to it I've
never thought this deeply at all about
myself because you just be listening and
you'll you'll be listening to a sentence
and just randomly halfway through
sentence YouTubers will have this like
audio Spike yeah and it's like oh it's
clearly a cut yeah and it's like or even
just it's just slight but it's like ah
it's like it's I don't like it so it's
like when I I do all the I like audio
work I don't know why I like doing all
the audio work and when I take out all
the lip smacks it'll take out like 3 000
of them and I'm like all these these
people don't have to listen to 3 000.
it's like with with YouTubers that do a
bunch of cuts right it does kind of lend
it to our lend well to the cut but every
time they cut they're restarting so they
start loud again yeah because they
didn't mean to but every cut is them
restarting and they're loud because you
start loud just because the way the way
that how speaking works is that you
don't have volume control very well on
the very first thing you said yeah
because you're just pushing air out so
it's quiet I think you got to get the
vocal cords yeah yeah it's quite like
explosive more explosive I don't want to
get you forget
you know but that's how it is so yeah
tip that's how you go top tip I think
I'm lucky that just my narrations has
always been like high energy yeah yeah
it lends well to high energy people but
if you're trying to sound
like just calm and just trying to talk
and narrate naturally or if you're doing
slow narration or you're doing dramatic
narration it's very important that's
where the birth of the what's up guys
literally literally that's literally
where it starts wait actually like I
feel like that's where it started it's
like it's that style version of that
that style has evolved because people
would just start by saying like what's
up guys and then it would Trail off
immediately yeah right not intentionally
but that style is just loud compared to
everything else and the thing that like
even with voiceover the thing that got
me too is like depending on the time of
day that you do it okay you didn't know
about this tell me tell me tell me so
because because my videos are so long
yeah and they could be like the last
one's like an hour of VoiceOver
you can't do it on one sitting okay yeah
I I can't you can't like my voice gets
too tired yeah and also if you have to
go back and let's say I go I notice a
problem and you have to do you have to
go and replace a clip how do you not
sound different okay that's yeah yeah
I've had I've had those problems yeah
that that's been very good I have the
secret what is the secret what is it the
secret is for at least for me uh
whenever if you do because as you as the
day goes on your voice changes yeah as
you have like more where the morning is
notably more yes and you get exactly and
you get like it does change so I would
always do my narration like
around the same time around the same
time like never earlier than a certain
time right because I've had I've just
it's been warmed up from talking yeah
yeah and just doing that made it like
way more consistent well I I noticed
it's the time of day but also it really
much depends on sometimes it's the
weather that yeah sometimes like when
it's a really humid day like recording
in the summer I sound totally different
than recording in the winter yeah
because the atmosphere is different yeah
it is different thank you like an issue
like for one video yeah yeah between
yeah you definitely can and even over
time like if you go back and hear your
other videos your voice does change oh
definitely definitely yeah we've got
action changes easily my accent has
changed a [ __ ] ton yeah I remember you
mentioning that yeah I don't know if I
think I watched a video that you were in
with oh gosh
my old accent you're mentioning it yeah
oh yeah yeah oh yeah I used to have like
a completely different accent but I mean
your voice changes all the time it's
very normal my voice if you go back in
my videos my narrow I didn't narrate
like I just kind of like I kind of just
talked and then I got sinus surgery and
my voice did change like significantly
right in my a lot of people commented on
it huh do you prefer your voice now is
then
I think so yeah like it sounds because
my nasal cavity got opened up so there's
like more resonance in it well I think
having some of it's better well I think
having a distinct voice helps a lot with
YouTube oh definitely I feel like you
definitely have a very very distinct
voice you know when your videos pop up I
know I'm watching and now I read video
it's just like
I don't know if I developed a distinct
Voice or if I just
like your voice is on the same level as
my mind as like chills like levels of
distinct on YouTube like no like notable
voices on YouTube it's like Nile red but
what I've never I've never said like
what's unique about it I don't know it's
just like when you hear your voice
there's no mistaking it that it's you
talking it's it's your Cadence so
yeah that that it changed because of
doing voice over like for the channel it
would irritate me when I would because I
can't slur words right no of course not
yeah so I would just enunciate like very
yeah you're very clear it's impossible
for me I was like I wish I had that
power man I would I just became very
aware of it yeah I think it just made me
so conscious of how I spoke yeah yeah
because you speak like that off camera
as well so it's like it's clearly like
yeah I'm sure there's like some voice uh
over like elements to it as well but I
think just naturally you've grown the
ability voiceover yeah yeah yeah yeah I
remember when I first met you I was like
oh he sounds exactly like he does his
videos now what I've got here
he sounds scripted I just sound scripted
in real life every conversation is
scripted and I think it's cool that you
have a voice for people like wow yeah I
talked and then they're like do the
thing yeah yeah I just love it like why
did you oh it's good it's good it's good
because there's a lot of YouTubers where
it's like they have the a YouTuber voice
and then they have their real life voice
and it's it's the same but it's also
like the way that they say certain
phrases and the way that they you know
the Cadence of some sentences is very
much like a performative manner yeah on
YouTube whereas like in real life it's
not so much like it I would say that
they're
E I mean I think everyone has that like
myself included right
um
in my sense it's like there are certain
senses I can't say on script because I
don't think it's they I just don't think
they have a good sound to them right
right so like there are certain things I
wish I could say but I can't like what
off of my head I don't know but it's
like if I'm trying to like word
something right saying the word sentence
in a certain way just doesn't sound nice
and sometimes I try to come up with all
these different ways on how to like move
the sentence around I use a different
word yeah and I can't come up with it so
I just can't say the sentence that makes
sense that's pretty normal though I
think for voiceover yeah like certain
things like it's very tough for me to do
voiceovers that other people give me the
uh script the script because like you
said like I sound very similar to the
voiceover and it's because I don't know
why since the beginning of doing YouTube
I always wanted to be I like as close to
real as possible yeah cool so because of
that like I don't
I don't know why I just try to be like
as it's like the performative side to an
extent and the natural one don't it's
not it's not like one of them is like up
here it's like they both kind of come
closer together in a way I just want
everything to be like as real and
genuine as possible and that was like
since it started like I would never like
I even before I did any endorsements I
was like I will never endorse like
anything in any way that I don't truly
like use or enjoy myself yeah and that
was even before like the prospect of
anything like that right that makes
sense yeah because I totally get you
about the whole script things and
sometimes things sounding wrong because
these are just gonna test but whenever
we have like an ad reads I can't do it
so much because it's not written within
my voice yeah so it just so it's so
unnatural for like my mouth to I guess
make those movements and it just takes a
while to like like warm up I guess I
feel I feel it's definitely a common
thing with a lot of YouTubers who write
their own scripts in their videos yeah
like I feel with like it's like me and
Connor for example who don't necessarily
script our stuff all the way where it's
like it's I think it's a little bit
easier because we're not used to the
rhythm of you know a certain way that we
say certain things that only we can
write yeah I think I agree but I think
that for me too like just maybe think of
something how
as I would write the script out because
it's I think this is probably why my
voice and like the way I spoke changed I
want to be as real as possible yeah so
it became very very aware of times I
repeated words yeah when I said um yeah
when I did a lot of these things so like
any time I would say the same word twice
I didn't like that and I became aware
even in like everyday speech yeah I will
not say the same word twice
I will try I I just was like I became a
I don't know why I just stopped doing it
right right so but I mean that's not
necessarily a bad house it's not bad
vocabulary it's off the charts no it's
just like it sounds bad it's only really
occurring to me right now like let's say
this you want to call this like a bottle
yeah if I were to say like oh like this
bottle is really cool
I if I were to have to say the word
bottle twice in like really close
together I would probably just not say
it I'd say this I wouldn't say bottle
all right because I just became so oh
you know you wouldn't replace it with
like a synonym like you wouldn't be like
this bottle is really cool I really like
this container that that too close is
weird yeah but it's like I became
abundantly aware when like in a script
so I'm gonna be like this bottle is
really cool it's a bottle yeah I bought
this bottle the other day because I like
bottles like that started just hurting
me so bad yeah so I would be like just
in every day
speech I stopped repeating words if they
were too close and sometimes I always
get a sentence that I couldn't find a
replacement and I just kind of wouldn't
mention it I think this or like like I
just give up or I won't mention it that
makes sense I mean that but it makes no
sense because people aren't and it got
really bad in text messages because
sometimes
that sounds weird I couldn't find a way
to not repeat the word right so I would
just not reply
I think that's OCD no that's what I said
I realized I'm like my life is not a
performance there was no repercussions
to it was the script good what what
script yeah oh oh okay yeah sorry it
wasn't like there were no repercussions
it's just that I started noticing the
lip smacking and the repeated words so
much that when I heard other people do
it
especially with my brother I'd be like
what is this guy doing like that's like
it would feel like nails on a chalkboard
so that when I would do it I would
suddenly become like weirdly self-aware
and it would stop me okay okay that
makes sense but that's why I feel like
it changed the way I spoke and the way I
did a lot of stuff because I was like so
aware I became super aware of the way I
spoke this isn't making the murder of
Melrose it's like this is the the back
back story I gotta I gotta loosen things
up how many there's so many text
messages
you didn't even get to talk about wire
in Japan or anime or anything I mean
like I I mean everything else you told
us so it goddamn interesting that I
didn't give a [ __ ] about asking about it
honestly I hardly say I'm gonna I'm
hardly said a word this podcast well I'm
just like I just want to hear so yeah I
just want to hear more about what the
[ __ ] the Antics you've got on yeah
sometimes you just have some guests who
just have such [ __ ] weird stories and
lives
because you obviously like especially
when when you're the type of YouTuber
that you are that through your YouTube
videos we don't really get to see your
personality yeah yeah so I I find it I
find there's just so much more questions
to ask yeah that's why I find it fun
coming on like in doing so because I
just I mean before the podcast that like
uh 53rd was yeah before safety third I
never talked about anything yeah if you
didn't know anything about it she used
to just sat in the corner well I meant
like I was very not like everything is
scripted right so you be very careful
what you say like they didn't know
anything about you yeah no again I would
never be like I'm just gonna make a
video talking about myself like why yeah
right I mean I was the same way I wear
before trash taste everyone only knew me
for my scripts yeah nothing about what
you did to your personality yeah like
that right and it's like unless you're
gonna go out and make like proper
content it feels like a lot of work yeah
whereas like it feels like what you're
trying to get out is casual yeah but
you're now going down the same path of
just like making more scripted content
to try to show how you're like casual
side no exactly so until the podcast I
just kind of didn't really happen I can
see why now through this podcast you
never did a draw in my life because it
would have just been [ __ ]
hey yawning just like so when I was nine
I bought my first blow tool which is
like you had a wild the one thing I'd
say is because it's my friend I should
give him a shout out Greg I don't know
if he's gonna watch this he's in another
he's he's an Australia
he he was the guy did like all the
childhood stuff right projects with I
remember him coming to me
um I went to team elementary schools in
but then like not the same high school
or Stasia but then we reunited in
University yeah I remember him telling
me he's like yeah in this time like I
talked to a lot of people about my
childhood and he goes I would literally
be like oh you know when you were
younger and you'd like build bike ramps
and they're like
no yeah he's like you know like yo you
play with fireworks
and he's like you know like BB guns and
they're like
I like to play video games I like read
books I play video games he's like I
started to realize my childhood wasn't
normal